in a move of total desperation
donald trump has announced that he is
now going to consider pardoning
edward snowden in a completely obvious
gambit
to maybe try to take control of the
election and appeal to
some voters and this is super
interesting partially because donald
trump previously called
for edward snowden to be executed it's
also partially interesting because it's
not clear whether this would actually
help donald trump so let's
take it from the top edward snowden is
the former nsa contractor who's been
living in russia for years to escape
prosecution here in the united states
for leaking classified documents that
exposed
that the nsa and the government other
government agencies
were doing this mass bulk surveillance
trump
was asked about edward snowden over the
weekend and here's what he had to say
do you want to give edward snowden a
pardon and bring him back you
you once suggested well i'm going to
look at it i mean i'm not that aware of
the snowden situation but i'm going to
start looking at it
there are many many people it seems to
be a split decision that many people
think that
he should be somehow treated differently
and other people think he did
very bad things and i'm going to take a
very good look at it okay
i mean i i've i've seen people that are
very conservative and very liberal and
they agree on the same issue they
agree both ways uh i'm going to take a
look at that very strongly edward
snowden yeah please
so in trump's mealy-mouthed and confused
way
he's saying yeah he's going to look at
pardoning edward snowden now remember
that donald trump previously said in a
tweet quote
snowden is a spy who should be executed
but if it and he could reveal obama's
records i might become a major fan
trump tweeted about edward snowden
snowden is a traitor and a disgrace make
no mistake he is no hero
in fact he is a coward who should come
back and face justice
trump tweeted snowden is a liar and a
fraud
trump tweeted like it or not edward
snowden is a spy
and should be tried as a spy he has
stolen invaluable information and
damaged us with other nations
trump a second time with the execution
of snowden tweeting
snowden is a spy who has caused great
damage to the u.s a spy in the old days
when our country was respected and
strong
would be executed trump tweeted
hilariously
message to edward snowden you're banned
from miss universe
unless you want me to take you back home
to face justice so i could go on
trump has 45 tweets about snowden
but the point is trump could not have
been more against
snowden for year after year after year
until now
and to be clear the problem here is not
that trump might
change his mind changing one's mind is
good you learn something new
you re-evaluate your position and your
belief might
be modified that's a beautiful thing we
should applaud that rather than ridicule
it the issue here is trump hasn't
learned anything
other than maybe pardoning snowden would
help me in november trump
says in his answer i don't know much
about him
but i'm going to look at a pardon trump
hasn't become informed about snowden
and now thinks maybe we pardon him trump
hasn't suddenly
come out against the surveillance that
snowden exposed it's merely trump
thinking
could this help me in november maybe it
could he barely has an idea who edward
snowden is or what he did
unless putin has been talking to him
about it which would be another
situation altogether
so what trump means by i'm going to take
a look at it
is i'm going to think about whether it
might
win me some votes in november that's
absolutely all that this
is one of our sponsors today is
hydrant and they are giving my audience
25
off your first order this has been a
game changer for me this is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water
to rehydrate your body because it is
packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most
that's sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc
and because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way
of getting yourself rehydrated and it
tastes awesome there's a variety of
flavors
i have blood orange which i love you can
also get grapefruit
and lime a lot of us don't even realize
when we're dehydrated a lot of the time
and
it's become a really a great part of my
daily routine
if i'm under hydrated i'm affected
physically
i'm affected mentally and i think
you never fully understand this until
you use hydrant for the first time
i get a great uh a boost of energy when
i'm
properly hydrated if i've been
dehydrated they also have a version with
caffeine which i love
if and when that's what i'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video